but we're going to begin with the
breaking news from ukraine secretary of
state anthony blinken and defense
secretary lloyd austin have met with
ukraine's president in the capital city
of kiev this is for the first time since
russia started this war two months ago
they arrived on easter sunday for
orthodox christians bringing hundreds of
millions of dollars in aid in the latest
show of western solidarity during
russia's relentless and deadly siege in
eastern ukraine chris livesay is in
keeve with more on the story chris good
morning to you
good morning gail president zielinski
had told world leaders if you come to
ukraine please don't take quote tragic
selfies but bring the weapons we're
asking for this weekend marking eastern
ukraine zielinski got his wish
after a hushed meeting in ukraine's
capital secretary of state anthony
blinken said this morning in poland that
ukraine is succeeding russia continues
to try to brutalize parts of the country
but ukrainians are standing up they're
standing strong and they're doing that
with the support that we have
coordinated from literally around the
world
support ukraine has been begging for as
russia now aims to pummel into
submission ukraine's east as well as the
south
launching at least six cruise missiles
into the black sea port city of odessa
over this orthodox easter weekend
a strike on an apartment building killed
eight people including a mother and her
three-month-old city officials say the
father comes to save what memories are
left
she was a great mother friend with all
the best qualities yuri says
my world died killed by a russian
missile
shattering hopes of an easter ceasefire
in her pin the sight of a brutal russian
massacre
finally it wasn't the air raid sirens
that were sounding
but the holiday is bittersweet
this sister is has
the taste of war survivors like daria
had to celebrate for the first time
without family members that were
slaughtered
russian occupants
killed my parents
they destroyed
our house and then
they killed my parents by shooting
do you have a special prayer for this
easter
i want
that
the war
will
be finished and
i want
that
i want putin
will be died
and i want
that all
russian occupants will be died also
for ukrainians like daria every u.s
dollar and every u.s bullet counts one
ukrainian lawmaker told me at the
beginning of the invasion the west
thought ukraine would lose but the
latest aid especially that heavy
artillery shows their minds are changing
vlad
chris lives say in ukraine chris when
you hear the pain and the anguish in
that young woman's voice knowing that
people around the world got to celebrate
ramadan easter passover and theirs is so
horrific chris thank you very much